you may have noticed that I'm wearing
two different shoes it probably looks
funny it definitely feels funny but I
wanted to make a point let's say my left
shoe corresponds to sustainable
footprint meaning humans consume less
natural resources than our planet can
regenerate and emit less carbon dioxide
than our forests and ocean can reabsorb
that's a stable and healthy condition
today's situation is more than my other
shoe it's very oversized at the 2nd of
August in 2017 we have already consumed
all resources our plant can regenerate
this year this is like spending all your
money our till the 18th of a month and
then leading a credit from the bank for
the rest of the time for sure you can do
this for Samantha Niro but if you don't
change your behavior sooner or later you
will run into big problems we all know
that devastating effects of this
excessive exploitation global warming
rising of the sea levels melting of the
glacier and pole eyes increasingly
extreme climate patterns and more the
enormity of this problem really
frustrates me but frustrates me even
more is that your solutions to this but
we keep doing things like we always did
today I want to share with you how a new
solar technology can contribute to a
sustainable future of buildings
buildings consume about 40% of our total
energy demand so tackling this
consumption would significantly reduce
our climate emissions a building
designed a long sustainable principle
can produce all the power it needs by
itself to achieve this you first have to
reduce the consumption as much as
possible by using well insulated vaults
or windows for instance these
technologies are commercially available
then you need energy for warm water and
heating so you can get this in a
renewable way from the Sun the solar
thermal installations or from the ground
and air with heat pumps also these
technologies are a
then you're left with a need for
electricity in principle there are
several ways to get to renewable
electricity but how many buildings do
you know which have a windmill on the
roof or a water power plant in the
garden probably not so many because
usually it doesn't make sense but the
Sun provides abundant energy to our
roofs and facades
the potential to harvest this energy at
our building surfaces is enormous
let's take Europe as an example if you
would utilize all areas which have a
nice orientation to the Sun and they're
not overly shaded the power generated by
photovoltaics would correspond to about
30 percent of our total energy demand
but today's photovoltaics had some
issues they do offer a good cost
performance ratio but they aren't really
flexible in terms of the design and this
makes us statics a challenge people
often imagine pictures like this when
thinking about solar cells at buildings
this may work for solar farms but when
you think of buildings of streets of
architecture aesthetics does madam this
is the reason but we don't see many
solar cells at buildings today they just
don't match our team is working in a
totally different solar cell technology
which is called organic photovoltaics or
OPV the term organic describes that the
material used for light absorption and
charge transport are mainly based on the
element carbon and other metals they
utilize the mixture of a polymer which
is set up by different repeating units
lightly pearls in a pearl chain and a
small molecule which has the shape of a
football and is called fullerene these
two compounds are mixed and dissolved to
become an ink and like ink they can be
printed with simple printing techniques
like slot dye coating in a continuous
roll-to-roll process on flexible
substrates the resulting thin layer is
the active layer absorbing the energy of
the Sun this active layer is extremely
effective you only need a layer
thickness of 0.2 micro meters to absorb
the energy of the Sun this is 100 times
thinner than
human here to give you another example
take one kilogram of the basic polymer
and use it to formulate the active ink
with this amount of ink you can print a
solar cell with the size of a complete
football field so OPV is extremely
material efficient which i think is a
crucial thing when talking about
sustainability after the printing
process you can have a solar module
which could look like this looks a bit
like a plastic foil and actually as many
of its features it's lightweight
spendable and it's semi-transparent but
it can harvest energy of the Sun
outdoors and also of these indoor lights
as you can see with a small illuminated
LED you can use it in its plastic form
and take advantage of its low weight and
it's Bend ability the first is important
when thinking about buildings in warmer
regions here the roofs are not designed
to be rotational a heavy loads
they aren't designed for snow in winter
for instance so heavy silicon solar
cells cannot be used for light
harvesting but these lightweight solar
foils are very well suited the bend
ability is important if you want to
combine the solar cell with membrane
architecture imagine the sails of the
Sydney Opera as power plants
alternatively you can combine the solar
foils with conventional construction
materials like glass many glass facade
elements contain a full any way to
create laminated safety glass it's not a
big deal to add a second foil in the
production process
but then the facade element contains the
solar cell and can produce electricity
besides looking nice these integrated
solar cells come along with two more
important benefits do you remember the
solar cell attached to roof I've shown
before in this case you installed the
roof first and as a second layer of a
solar cell this is adding on the
installation costs in the case of
integrated solar cells at the side of
construction only one element is
installed being at the same time the
envelope of the building
the solar cell besides saving on your
installation cost this also saves
resources because the two functions are
combined into one element earlier I've
talked about optics I really like this
solar panel may be of a different taste
or different design needs no problem
with the printing process the solar cell
can change its shape and design very
easily this will give the flexibility to
architects to planners and building
owners to integrate this electricity
reducing technology as they wish I want
to stress that this is not just
happening in the labs it will take seven
more years to get to mass adoption but
we are at the edge of commercialization
meaning there are several companies out
there with production lines they are
scaling up their capacities and so are
we with the inks
this smaller footprint is much more
comfortable it is the right size the
right scale we have to come back to the
right scale when it comes to energy
consumption and making buildings carbon
neutral is an important part here in
Europe we have the goal to decarbonize
our building stock until 2050
I hope organic photovoltaics will be a
big part of this here are a couple of
examples this is the first commercial
installation of fully printed organic
solar cells commercial means that the
solar cells were printed on industrial
equipment the so-called solar trees the
part of the German Pavilion at the World
Expo in Milan in 2015 they provided
shading during the day and electricity
for the lighting in the evening you may
wonder why this hexagonal shape was
chosen for the solar cells easy answer
the architects wanted to have a specific
shading pattern on the floor and asked
for it and then it was printed as
requested being far from a real product
this freeform installation hooked the
imagination of the visiting architects
much more than we expected this other
application is closer to the projects
and applications we are targeting in an
office building in Sao Paulo Brazil
semi-transparent OPD panels are
integrated into the glass to say it's
having different needs first they
provided shading for the meeting rooms
behind second the logo of the company is
displayed in an innovative way and of
course electricity is produced reducing
the energy footprint of the building
this is pointing towards the future
their buildings are no longer energy
consumers but energy providers I want to
see solar cells seamlessly integrated
into our building shells to be both
resource efficient and a pleasure to
look at for roofs silicon solar cell
will often continue to be a good
solution but to exploit the potential of
office aids and other areas such as
semi-transparent areas curved surfaces
and shadings I believe organic
photovoltaics can offer a significant
contribution and they can be made in
reform architects and planners will want
them to thank you
[Applause]
[Music]